[Music]
this is what disruption of an
established industry looks like
that used car you found online
it's here
soaked safetied and secure and a
warehouse ready to go
crank a few levers and it's loaded up
and on the highway
and before you know it the car you so
carefully chose has been delivered to
your door
here's your brand new used car
haley reap never visited a used car lot
never even had to leave their house
it was a little weird but honestly like
it's so convenient i could just come
home from work and
know that my car was arriving later that
day
now take a breath the used car industry
hasn't gone fully online
yet in fact only two percent of canadian
consumers want a fully virtual
experience when buying their next car
but that number is being driven up by
younger consumers like erica webber
it's really hard to be
in the woods and live in the woods
without a car
she's a 33 year old from toronto who no
longer wants to be from toronto she
realized during the pandemic what was
important to her namely distancing
herself from the urban sprawl so she can
get closer to the bike trails and nature
walks she loves
a car as she sees it is her ticket out
of town the more i traveled with in
ontario i realized there was so much
more to see and so many more adventures
to be had and that meant that i would
need to go further my emotions have kind
of been all over the place you know
sometimes i get really excited and i get
really enthusiastic and i love the idea
of having the freedom and having my own
car
and then sometimes
i wonder if i'm going to find it and i
wonder if i'm going to end up with
something that i really do like
she admits the car world isn't her world
which is why she's enlisted nick dasco
the car nerd
it's not a dig it's his business name
nick helps pick the cherries from the
lemons
we're looking at about 10 to 12k by
having a smaller budget
it's uh it definitely comes with you
know a shorter list how short
with the average price of a used car
going up 48 percent in the last year to
35 000 and counting they're finding a
whole lot of lemons
it is definitely more of a challenge
because it has required people to spend
more money
on cars that
used to be dramatically cheaper in the
past 12 months i've had experiences
where
i'm seeing
cars priced for
close to if not more than they cost
brand new and these are now three years
old a wolverine attacked the driver's
seat
it's over 15 years old and you need an
appraisal for it i straight up don't
trust this dealership this car needs a
new front seat it could be worth a look
but that's sort of what 6 800 seems to
get you yeah
it's not just nick the nerd mark
mcmullen is a maven
[Music]
he's with mark wilson's better used cars
in guelph ontario and he's just as
baffled since well the advent of
automobiles themselves most used cars
went downhill in value well no more we
had a truck that we were all worried
about it was like march
2020 we're going on lockdown it was a
dodge ram 2500.
mcmullen sold that pickup for 41
900
the guy who bought it put 80 000
kilometers on the odometer and then sold
it back to mcmullen for forty four
thousand dollars it doesn't add up right
well mcmullen put it back on his lot for
forty six thousand nine hundred yet when
another dealer called to buy it he said
no because he needed the inventory for
his customers but when the dealer
offered 50 000 mcmullen sold the truck
yet again i keep saying this is
historical
like this has never happened never could
you buy a vehicle and drive it and it
actually appreciates
despite all this the appetite for cars
remains insatiable there are estimated
to be roughly 2 million consumers in
north america who are now in the market
to buy a new vehicle right now demand is
very strong and pent-up demand is even
stronger scosar bank auto sector analyst
rebecca young says on average canadians
have saved an extra eight thousand
dollars since early twenty twenty money
the auto industry desperately wants but
the dealers have a huge problem it's
taking them months to fulfill new
vehicle orders because they have so few
cars on their lots
what i think though is interesting and
anecdotal is that we now are seeing
frequently the term that i ordered a
vehicle pre-pandemic that was unheard of
people didn't say i ordered a vehicle
they would say i purchased a vehicle
earlier in the pandemic manufacturers
could point to a worldwide microchip
shortage for the decrease in car
production which was made worse with the
supply chain crisis and then if you take
the shortage of new cars and apply it to
the larger auto food chain it stands to
reason the used car sector will feel the
pinch as well
used car dealers get the bulk of their
inventory from two main sources rental
companies and leases
rental companies are constantly
refreshing their inventory but with so
few new vehicles coming in they're
holding on to their older cars
the same reasoning applies to drivers
with leases and when the lease comes due
that vehicle then enters the second hand
market what we've seen though is because
those
when those leases come up there's no new
vehicle to put them into and so you see
lease extensions going on right now back
to the manufacturing issues goods are no
longer moving around the world the way
they used to so young says ramping up
production isn't the solution
even if auto manufacturers operate at
full speed operate at three shifts per
day seven days a week and don't have
down times they still won't be able to
fully make up for that loss demand or
that pent-up demand over the course of
2022
change is inevitable of course car sales
are no longer so formal yet the basics
of shopping at a car lot have changed
little over the years
but pandemics as we've learned have a
way of forcing even the most resolute to
adapt during the beginning of the
pandemic necessity is the mother of
invention
so mcmullen turned to online sales and
ramped up delivering cars from the lot
to his customers front doors
the response was so positive that he's
now fully committed to developing a new
business model
ultimately he doesn't see consumers
walking away from the in-person
experience so he's creating a system
where a robust online presence
complements the existing business
if mcmullen is an agent of change dan
park is more of a disrupter
the common thread across all our
consumers is that they want just an
easier better way to buy a car
he's the ceo of clutch a canadian used
car vendor that operates entirely online
similar to carvana and vroom in the u.s
clutch's success he says is tied to its
growing reputation
if you look at other industries you know
the hotel industry the taxi industry
even dating you know i think even the
concept of online dating was a little
bit foreign is it easier to say data
mercedes versus date this person i think
so i mean you've got a 10-day money-back
guarantee that's not always true in the
in the dating world
perhaps taking a page from dating apps
clutch puts mountains of information
online about every car they sell
they fix what's broken and offer a 360
degree tour of the car
all in an effort to be transparent
with thousands of high quality cars to
choose from park is all in on clutch's
future he signed a deal to become the
official used car partner of the nhl and
is on track to deliver almost anywhere
in canada
we were you know selling hundreds back
then and now we're you know well into
the thousands per year
and so we've grown you know almost 10x
over the last couple years and what's
the goal i mean for us the goal is to be
the the most trusted provider of used
vehicles in the country
because of mcmullen and startups like
clutch consumers have never had more
choice without leaving home but there's
little any dealer can do to meet the
demand that exists in the market prices
are high supply is low leaving erica
weber still looking for her dream car
it's been a struggle she's not giving up
but economists don't foresee a
correction in prices until 2023
at the earliest
it's already been a long journey and i
feel like the road is a little bit
longer i wish i was a bit more
optimistic and hopeful about finding
something sooner and hopefully we'll get
there fingers crossed